i want to give the scrap life again
bring in a new purpose
my art is a mix of fantasy and common
sense
[Music]
my name is claudia coogler and i'm an
artist and i'm most known for making
moving robot sculptures
[Music]
i stumbled into making robots
i was making sculptures out of scrap
metal i found and then i started to move
those moving parts with air pressure
pistons
it started with a hat moving the jaw and
before i knew it i had a robot
[Music]
i find my scrapbook pretty much
everywhere i have got my eyes open all
the time potentially fantastic eye
[Music]
i mean there's every kind of shape you
can imagine
[Applause]
[Music]
when i built a band member i start
obviously with the music making parts of
fingers plugging or playing and then i
build
the character behind it
the special thing about my robots is
that they actually do play the music
themselves
[Music]
my robots play the bass guitar the drum
kit and they play the flutes
[Applause]
they got an affinity for punk rock
the whole band is called the one last
machine band
my robots perform all around the world
tech events
festivals university lectures or ted
talks
when people see the robots it's like
they freeze for a while there's this
moment of oh what's going on here and
then it's usually so it's a childish
gleam and
the joy
i like to use scrap metal because
there's so much waste in the world
you can't destroy you can only make it
better
my work is a constant game of chance and
that's what i really love about it
[Music]